welcome to this blitz video and playing
Buju from from germany and its own sent
a counter an opening our the
scandinavian is this right I know that
short has played this d3 set up a number
of times with them quite good results
but I'm probably playing it all wrong at
least I don't really know the point of
all this I knew one point is that you
can play quick quick g4 and f4 if he
retreats to to age five not to d7 and to
d7 is interesting probably I'm like once
to play knight c6 something like that
yeah he hit another Queen move yeah I
cannot cancel should I play deform after
all
then no another option is this
completely insane no I come on let's do
this it's of course very aggressive
trying 4g 595 using the Queen the Queen
position so yeah it probably has to do
something like that and now I'm I'm
banking on the fact that he's probably
not able to play 95 maybe is as a porn
sec I probably would would play that
instead of misplacing my night not so
sure that this is so bad but it looks it
looks a bit bit dodgy okay I exchanged
the advantage of the offside night for
the open edge file he needs to take now
cannot go g6 of course and i'm not sure
why is spending time ok so now i
exchanged the that wanted share to to
something so something else to the open
edge fault ok knight c6 intending maybe
95 and long castles which is of course
useful from
now the specialist I moved it to make my
bishop mobaile still Bishop e3 is not
playable yeah how to develop Queen each
other's night before coming I don't
really like the look of that
mm-hmm how to how to get this Bishop
into play maybe I need to play this
somewhat modest means and then maybe 20
22 g 2 or something and then long
castles mm-hmm they can play 94 now they
are 94 is good maybe I should have
played Queenie to first now d for I
cannot play nitey too because f3 Hanks
and I need to get the King out of out of
e1 hmm yeah yeah
Bishop c6 is another another problem
that's really uncomfortable
the ship's is six Jim yeah what the heck
went wrong down after H takes g3 white
must be excellent i cannot believe i'm
worse but it's a it's a problem here not
not sure what my mistake was
one problem was of a play Bishop e3
there's always night see to check so I'm
trying to prepare but should be three
here it's looking very ugly I know yeah
still f5 looks like blacks most logical
move IAM opening up the position i need
to take up a song on f6 and that's not
really something you like to do
now he's taking some time probably am
the other interesting moves where black
is also fine just with some development
move Bishop e7 or something nice taking
very long time after 15 moves we both
are down to one and a half minutes and
now smoothly don't really believe in
that the capture
no my king is relatively relatively safe
now okay so probably I need to set up
here the pin to threatening c3 okay now
he's tending to take yeah I need to keep
the King side closer and activate pieces
now e 6 and g6 are hanging oh I'll grab
that you can take on be too but um it's
it it should be it should be okay for me
we have six ruger for one should be okay
you know check you didn't see that one
black resign just just a little trick
yeah but what deck I really I really
thought that this should be it should be
a really great great for what and
somehow it wasn't maybe maybe I'm
completely misjudging this it's possible
but it looks like it should be good i
mean the H file until do this
differently I mean the rook is active on
the H file and I've got this cramping
porn but ok I've got a bad King and I
don't quickly get to Qasim hmm yeah he's
he's got I underestimated this one so
maybe I'm I shouldn't have played night
night to g3 I really have a hard time to
believe that black is ok here with this
with this piece maybe I need to to
switch plans
yeah it is tricky it is tricky let's
look like that hair for instance I need
to prepare long castles and he's um he's
got ya he can develop it's not not so
bad probably too optimistic I was too
optimistic him ITI mean in trouble in
various ways after that I'm in real
trouble maybe I'm I need to do something
else I know this this was was very very
ugly I thought fif actually is this bad
takes takes this one yeah I thought this
would be the way to go that he's got
more lines open in the game he didn't
really open open lines we had this
should be a should be okay for white I i
think my king is relatively secure and
I'm getting pawns back on g 696 its
opposite colored bishops so I'm not a
big problem a computer points out Queen
a five year I didn't see that one yeah
this is excellent for black I can have a
hard time covering it and the additional
problem is let's say I play this one is
harassing my queen yeah it's not too not
great at all yeah okay this okay what's
of course very lucky to get this gift
here and um yeah
the opening needs to be played in some
other way maybe yeah maybe g4 was just
too much okay thanks for watching